[Music]
hello everyone I'm Matthew and this is
my colleague Colleen and today we're
going to be going over what's new with
the Android runtime on Android also
known as art so what is art well art is
the software layer in between the
applications and the operating system it
provides mechanisms for executing java
language and call in applications to
accomplish this art does two things it
executes text files the intermediate
representation of android applications
through a hybrid model consisting of
interpretation just-in-time compilation
and profile based ahead of time
compilation art also does memory
management for Android applications
through an automatic automatic
reclamation through a garbage collector
this is a concurrent compacting garbage
collector so that there is less jank for
your applications now let's look at how
art has changed over the last few years
over the years there have been many
improvements to art in new got we
introduced profile guided compilation to
improve applications startup time reduce
memory usage and reduce storage
requirements also in new got we added a
a gyp much like dalvik used to have this
was done to remove the need for
optimizing apps that was kind of a big
problem during Android system updates
and in Oreo we added a new concurrent
compacting garbage collector to reduce
ram requirements have less jank as well
as accelerate allocations as you can see
here on the slide this new garbage
collector and they build a new one
pointer allocator that is 17 times
faster than the allocator in dalvik or
in KitKat
now we talked about what happened in the
past the West Loop in Android P first of
all there are new compiler optimizations
to help accelerate the performance of
calling code in Android this is
especially important since Collin is a
first-class programming language for
Android development next up we have
memory and storage optimizations to help
entry-level devices such as Android Go
devices this is important to help
improve the performance for the next
billion users and finally we have cloud
profiles device collected profiles from
the just-in-time compiler are uploaded
and aggregated in the cloud to enable
faster performance directly after
installation of applications ok so let's
start with Collin last year we announced
Collin as a first class officially
supported programming language for
Android development and then we began to
investigate the performance why Collin
you might ask well Collin is a safe
expressive concise object-oriented
language that is designed to be
interoperable with Java language the
reason art focuses on optimizing Collin
so that the developers can leverage all
of these language features while still
having fast and jank-free applications
let's see how it Collin optimizations
are normally performed inside of the
Android runtime usually optimizations
are performed in an investigative manner
and there's an order of preference for
fixing performance issues so that the
most amount of Collin applications can
actually benefit from the optimization
the preferred option is fixing a
performance issue inside of call link
and calling is the compiler developed to
byte jetbrains Google and Jeff reigns of
course work closely together on all
kinds of optimizations and fixes for
issues if we fix a performance issue
here it'll be able to be deployed to the
most amount of
applications alternatively if that
doesn't work then we consider fixing the
performance issue inside of byte code
converters fixing in the by code
converter will enable existing versions
of the Android platform to get the
performance fix and if that option
doesn't work the last option is to fix
the performance issue and the Android
runtime also known as art so the reason
that we might not want to fix an art
right away is because art is updated as
part of the android platform so that
means that not all devices will get the
fix now let's look at an example one
example of the calling optimization is
the parameter null check as you can see
here this is a simple method that just
returns the length of a string but the
string is nullable so what this means is
that the compiler inserts a null check
into the function byte code to actually
verify that the string is not null and
throw the corresponding exception if
required implemented in the byte code
the first step is loading the name of
the parameter and then invoking a
separate function to do the actual null
check there's some extra overhead here
as you might see because the invocation
in the common case you do the extra
invocation that goes to the function to
do the null check in this function in
turns if required called the third
function the throw the actual parameter
is null exception checks such as these
are commonly required for Java language
and call an interoperability because
Java language does not have a non
nullable property now let's see how we
can optimize this if we look at the
bytecode one of the first things we can
do is actually inline the method that
does the null check into the caller
after inlining this improves performance
because there's one less invocation and
from here you can see one other thing we
can do is that the the name of the
parameter is not actually required
unless as argument is null so from here
we can do code syncing
to move loading of the parameter name
inside of the conditional so overall
these two optimizations help performance
by removing one indication and Wynonna
loadings of a string literal
apart from this optimization we also
track collin performance on various
benchmarks other improvements here
include improved auto vectorization of
loops also intrinsic methods that are
specifically tailored for call encode
help improve performance there so the
art team is always working on improving
this performance okay now that we're
done Colin what about memory and storage
improvements
so since art is responsible for Java
language and Colin applications also
pretty important to just kind of make
sure that the programs don't use too
much memory I'd take too much space on
the device there have been several
improvements focusing on this area
including reducing the amount of space
and memory usage required by Dex files
now why are a mass storage import up in
storage optimizations important well
recall a lot last year we introduced a
new initiative called
Android go aiming at running the latest
versions of Android on entry-level
devices since these devices typically
have one gigabyte or less of RAM and
eight gigabytes or or less of storage
it's kind of important to focus on
optimizing these areas so that the users
can run enough applications and install
as many applications as they or more
applications than they would otherwise
be able to now this isn't just for
Android go premium devices also benefit
from optimizations in these two areas
but since they have more resources
normally is to a lesser degree anyways
before we talk about RAM and storage
optimizations let's do a little bit of a
review about how applications work on
your Android devices an application
normally comes in an application package
kit also known as an apk inside of the
apk there are usually one or more dalvik
executable files also known as Dex files
that contain instructions that art
use this to either interpret or compile
your application this Dex files are
required to be quickly accessed during
execution they were mapped directly into
memory during applications startup so
that art can have quick access this
means that this there is a startup cost
as well as a ram cost proportional to
the size of the Dex file
finally Dex files are usually stored
twice on the device the first place they
are stored is inside of the application
package kit and then the second place
they are stored is in an extracted form
so that art can have faster access
during application startup without
needing to extract from the zip file
each time now let's take a closer look
at the contents of Dex files within a
Dex file there are several sections
containing different types of data
related to the applications but where is
the space going into Dex file one way to
do this is you can kind of calculate
where the space is going for you to Dex
file and average out the results this
chart here is for the top 99 most
downloaded applications in the Play
Store and you can see that the largest
section is the code item section
containing the Dex instructions used by
art the next largest section is the
string data section and this section
contains the string literals loaded from
code method names class names and field
names combined these two sections are
around 64% of the Dex file so they're
pretty important areas to optimise let's
see if there's a way we can reduce the
size of these sections one new feature
introduced in Android P is called
compact Dex the goal of compact Dex is
simple reduce the size of Dex files to
get memory and storage savings on the
device from the previous slide we saw
that some sections are larger than
others so it's important to just focus
on the large sections to get the most
savings where's our code items there are
more often deduplicated and there also
have their headers from save a space for
each method essentially inside of the
application
and another thing here worth noting
about the string Deena is that large
applications frequently shipped multiple
Dex files in their apk because of
dx-format limitations
specifically the 64k method limit means
that you can only have 64,000 kind of
method references in a single dex file
before needing to add another one to
your application and every time you add
another dex file this causes duplication
specifically a string data that could
otherwise be stored only once compact
Dex shrinks this by providing
deduplication across the Dex files in
the apk now let's go to the generation
process first let's look at how Dex
files are processed on android oreo the
first step run by Dex toad a head of
time compiler is that the Dex files are
extracted from the apk and stored in a
be Dex container the reason they are
extracted as I mentioned earlier is so
that they can be loaded more efficiently
during applications startup one other
thing here worth noting is the profile
the profile as introduced in nougat is
uh essentially data about the
application execution including which
methods are executed during startup what
methods are hot so compiled by the JIT
compiler and what classes are loaded on
Oreo we are we're already optimizing the
Dex file stored in the be Dex container
by late applying layout optimizations
and also we were deciding which methods
to compile based on what methods are hot
in the Dex file now let's look at Dex
processing on Android pee in Android pee
the out of time compiler now converts
the Dex files to a more efficient
compact Dex representation inside of the
container when the addition here is the
introduction of a shared data section
specifically data that's present in
multiple Dex files will be in the shared
data section only once so it kind of
deduplicate data that's commonly shared
and one of the most commonly shared
things here is the string data so this
is how we reduce the large string data
section that we saw
earlier finally since the conversion is
automatically done on device this means
that all existing applications can get
the benefits of compact decks without
needing to recompile their apks okay so
let's look at one example of how we
actually shrink the Dex code items apart
from the instructions each code item has
a 16 byte header and then most of the
values in the header are usually small
values so what we do here is we shrink
the fields in the header to be four bits
each and then we have an optional free
header to extend them as required the
pre header is 0 bytes in most of the
cases but can be up to 12 bytes in the
worst case so other than the pre header
we also shrink the instruction count
since the average method is not going to
be that large we shrink this down to 11
bits instead of 32 bits and use the five
remaining this four flags that are our
specific finally we move the debug
information into a separate space
sufficient table to help enable more
deduplication of the code items overall
this optimization saves around 12 bytes
per code item in the compact Dex file
and here are the results for the top 99
most outlet apks so the average space
required by the Dex files on a device is
around 11 point 6 percent smaller and
then also other than the storage savings
we also get memory savings because the
Dex files are resident in memory during
application usage at least partially
resident memory and one more thing here
let's go over the layout optimizations a
little bit so even though we had
introduced the JIT profiles in Android
and we did not have any layout
optimizations back then so what this
means the Dex is kind of randomly
ordered and not disregarding the usage
pattern in Android oh we added this type
of layout optimisation that groups the
methods used during applications start
up together and the message that are hot
so that means their code is frequently
accessed during
execution together this seems like a
pretty good a pretty big win so far
let's see what we did for Android P in
Android P we have more flexible profile
information which enables us to put the
methods that are used only during
startup together this helps reduce the
amount of memory used because the
application or the operating system can
remove those pages from memory after
startup we also put the hot code
together since it's frequently accessed
during execution and finally we put the
code I just never touched at all during
execution at the end so that is not
loaded into memory unless required and
the reason that these layout
optimizations are important is because
they improve locality and reduce how
many parts as a Dex file are actually
loaded into memory during an application
usage and startup so if you improve the
locality here you can get startup
benefits memory reduction and of
production and memory usage and now the
killeen or cloud profiles
Thank You Matthew hello everyone my name
is Colleen and I'm here today to present
you how we plan to improve and scale up
the Android runtime profiling
infrastructure however before we start
profiling is a rather overloaded term
when you speak about profiling in
today's presentation we're going to
refer to the metadata that they're on
droids runtime captures about the
application execution metadata that are
going to be feed into a profile guided
optimization process we're gonna see how
we extend the own device capabilities in
order to drive performance right at
install time before we jump into what is
new and how much it was let me briefly
remind you how Android uses profile
guided optimizations this is an
efficient technique that we introduced
in Android luga as part of a hybrid
execution model hybrid means that the
code being executed can be in three
different optimization States at the
same time the primary goal of this
technique is to improve all key metrics
of the application performance we're
talking about faster application startup
time reduce memory footprint a better
user experience by providing less junk
during usage less disk space used by the
compiler artifacts which means more disk
space for our users and nonetheless an
increased battery life because we do
heavy optimizations
when the device is not used rather than
at the use time how does this work it
all starts when the Play Store installs
the application but first we do very
very light optimizations and we have the
application ready to go for the user but
first launch the application we'll start
in what we call an interpretation mode
but the runtime execuse the application
code it discovers the most frequently
used methods and the most important
methods to be optimized that's when a
JIT System game kicks in and will
optimize the code during this time
the JIT system also records what he
called a profile information this
profile information essentially
encapsulates data about the methods that
are being executed and about the classes
that are being loaded every now and then
we dump this profile to disk so that we
can reuse it later once the device is
put aside and is not in used a state
which we call idle maintenance mode
we're gonna use that profile to drive
profile guided optimizations
the result is an optimized optimized app
it will eventually replace the original
state now when the user really launches
the app it will have a much snappier
start of time the much better steady
state performance execution and overall
the battery will drain last in this
state the application will be
interpreted just in time compound or
pre-optimized now just how efficient is
this technique we gather some data from
the field
for Google Maps application here you can
see two charts the left one presents
data from a marshmallow build you can
see that the startup time is pretty
constant over time it does not fluctuate
and this is pretty much expected you
don't want to have deviations here
however on the right hand side you can
see that in nuga the startup time drops
over time eventually it stabilizes off
of being about 25% faster than it will
used to be at install time and this is
great news it means that the more the
user uses the app the more we can
optimize it and over time the
performance gets better and better this
is great but we can do better and we
want to do better there shouldn't be
needy we shouldn't need to wait for
optimal performance and our goal is
called profiles is to deliver near
optimal performance - right after
install time without having to wait for
the application to be profile
so let's see how it's gonna how this is
gonna work
let me introduce you the idea of cloud
profiles this is based on made two key
observations first one is that usually
apps have many commonly used code paths
that are shared between a multitude of
users and devices
take for example classes loading the
restart up time eg device will have its
own specific set however globally we can
extract a common intersection of all
those classes and that's valuable data
for us to optimize upon second we know
that most app developers roll out their
apps incrementally starting with alpha
beta channels or for example 1 2 % of
the user base and the idea behind toad
profiles is to use this initial set of
alphabetic Channel users to bootstrap
performance for the rest of the users so
how is gonna work once we have an
initial set of devices we're gonna
extract the profile information about
your apk from those devices we're gonna
upload that information to play and then
we're gonna combine everything we're
going to aggregate whatever comes in and
we're gonna generate what we call a core
application profile this 4 profile will
contain information she's relevant
across all devices and not just a single
one when a new device requests for that
application to be installed we're gonna
deliver this core profile alongside the
main application apk to the device
locally the device will be able to use
that data to perform profile guided
optimizations right at install time that
will deliver an improved code startup
performance and much but it's better
steady-state performance over time
now having profiles in the cloud offers
much more opportunities than directly
influencing the app performance with a
profile guided optimizations the core
profiles offers available data for
examples were developers to act upon and
we believe there is enough information
there so that developers can tune their
own applications we're going to explore
how you can share this data later now
you can see in this workflow that to
deliver such a thing we need support
from Android platform and play a live in
today's presentation gonna focus on
language support so what did we do in P
to support this lifecycle we added new
interfaces that will allow us to extract
the profile and bootstrap the
information from the cloud the
functionality is available to all system
level apps which acquire the necessary
permissions and in our case play is just
a consumer the to ape IP is I'm talking
about our profile extractions and these
are exposed here a new platform manager
we call it art manager the second API is
profile installation and this is
seemingly integrated into the current
installer session what we did here is to
add a new kind of installation artifact
that the platform understands we call
this text metadata files essentially in
a similar way to the case the text
metadata files are archives which will
contain information in how the runtime
can optimize the application initially
this text metadata files will contain
the core profile that I mentioned about
earlier but install time play will
deliver these files if they are
available to the device where they will
be streamlined into the text optimizer
on device
it is worthwhile mentioning that we will
offer support for Google Play dynamic
delivery so if you plan to split the
functionality of your application of the
in different apks all DPS will have
their own text metadata files so let's
take a look how everything fits together
from the device perspective you remember
that I presented this diagram in the
beginning showing how the profiling
works locally let's focus here just on
the profile file on the application once
we will give once we managed to capture
a profile file we're going to add strip
this information to play on players that
mention will aggregate this data if many
many other profiles and only have a
called profiles we're going to deliver
it to our new users as a call profile
the idea of the core profile is not to
replace own device profiling it's only
to bootstrap the profile optimizations
so essentially instead of starting with
a completely blank state about your
application will already know what are
the most commonly executed cause paths
and we'll be able to start optimizations
from there so now essentially what was a
pure on device profile feedback loop it
gets extended if a cloud on onand
now I keep talking about this core
profile and I think it's important to
dedicate a bit more attention to it so
let's talk a bit how we're gonna build
it we already know that on device from
one execution to the other the profiles
aggregated quite well they reach a
stable point pretty fast that means that
it was not reoccupied the application
over and over and over again after a few
optimization steps will stop however
that's data from one device how well
does it work when you try to do it cross
devices how many samples you will need
in order to get to a robust reliable
profile we looked at our own Google
applications and we try to figure that
up here you can see a plot which
represents the amount of information the
core profiles relative to the total
number of aggregations the y axis
represents the amount of information and
the actual value
marek value is not important there what
is important from this graph is act
actually from 20 2014 and of a number of
profile aggregations the information in
the profile reaches a plateau and that's
very important it sends a very important
message it means that the alpha beta
Channel users will provide us with
enough data to build a poor profile and
it means that the majority of the
production users of your application
will always have the best possible
experience
so how do we actually aggregate the
information I mentioned before that in
the profile you will find information
about classes and methods on device this
is roughly how it looks like we're going
to take all the executions that we have
seen before and we'll create a union of
everything that you've seen in the
aggregated profile you will have
information about classes methods about
everything that you've seen on cloud
however we don't really want everything
we only want the common executed code
path and what we are doing instead of
having a union will have be having a
smart intersection with the only keeping
the information relevant to all
executions meaning we're going to filter
out all the outliers the result is what
we call the core profile which only
keeps the most commonly seen samples and
this is what's gonna gonna get
eventually to the device how will that
is work let's look again at data
captured from Google Apps we tasted this
across a variety of application and here
are the results of some representative
ones in this set you can find
application which relies on lated code
for example google camera or
applications which have much which are
much more java oriented say Google Maps
or Google Docs for google camera for
example get a start of time improvement
of about twelve point six percent and
that's excellent given that the
application itself doesn't have a lot of
Java code
however for maps or dogs which are
heavily Java based we can see that the
optimizations improves the startup time
by about twenty eight percent or forty
three percent across the board you can
see an average of about twenty percent
improvement and that obviously depends
with what the application is doing how
much Java code is being used and so on
now I mention in the beginning that
besides improving the application
performance directly via profile guided
optimizations the profile of also offer
much more opportunities I'm gonna
present a short use case study and walk
you through some important aspects that
the profiles can reveal about your
application during this use case study
I'm gonna focus on a single question are
we shipping unnecessary code to the
clients are you let's take a look at
some data again this case study reflects
the state of some Google Apps that it
tested we see that on average we profile
about 1415 percent of the code and about
85 percent of the code remains on
profile when you spread the distribution
you can see for example that in some
apps five to ten percent of the code
gets profiled in some otherwise even 50
percent of the code gets profile and
this is the rather intriguing result and
the reason for that is that if the code
is not profiled that most likely means
that it might not have ever been
executed obviously that's it for a good
case I mean the code for example can be
unexpected error code pass right we all
want the applications to be reliable in
a robust and the error handling must be
there or it never gets executed you may
have backwards compatibility code
support for previous API level and such
you may have features which are not used
on all devices may have very features
very targeted and you may also have a
lot of unnecessary code lying around
maybe by including libraries that you
don't really use now it's a bit hard to
break down the percentage for this disk
attacker is and there can be other
reasons why we didn't profile the code
but the skewed distribution here is a
strong indication there is a lot of room
to deal true of improvement for a decade
the code can be reorganized or trim down
for better efficiency for example Google
Play introduced dynamic delivery schemes
which may help you reduce the code that
you share by targeting features only to
certain users and that's something that
you might want to look at and take
advantage of so we believe that the
result quite a bit of unnecessary code
lying around at least in our own apks
now since we focus on the proof on the
code that actually doesn't get profile
is there anything that we can extract
out of the profile code to understand
this let me talk a bit about different
categories of profile code when the
application code is being profiled the
runtime will try to label it depending
on its stage and you will have a label
for the startup category for the post
startup Pat aghori and for the hot
category obviously these are pretty
self-explanatory
the hot category of the code is
essentially what the runtimes in to be
the most important part of your code
it's important to keep in mind that
these are not is joined say for example
that a method foo is being executed
this can be executing early startup can
be executing during post sort of time
and can also be marked as hot for
example if you have a very heavy
computation during that method now if
you know the code which is executing to
the in startup time if you focus on that
you'll be able to lower the startup time
of the application as such the first
impression that the users will have upon
your application will be very good if
you look at the post startup code it
will help you for example layout the
application text by code that will lead
to memory improvements and will be much
smoother on low-end devices
as for the hot code this is the code
that should get the most attention for
your optimization efforts
it's the code that is most heavily
optimized by the runtime and it might be
so because the runtime identified that
it is very beneficial to invest time
there and it's what if you for example
start to it try to improve the quality
and the performance of your app this is
where you should spend your effort or
your initial effort now for this is
important like how much code of your
applications actually being marked as
hot because if everything is hot then
everything can be optimized so that's
not really not really useful let me show
you the breakdown of these three
categories in this graph you can see on
the red columns the percentages for the
profile code and the knot profile code
this will sum up to 100% and it's what I
showed you earlier they are here just
for the reference the blue boxes show
the percentages of the startup code the
post startup code and the hot one
relative to the total text by code so
don't expect it to add 100% also one but
one piece of code can be in different
categories at the same time as you can
see here the average on average about
10% of the application Dex by code is
being marked as hot and this indicates
that when you focus on your app
optimizations you can dedicate the
attentional starting with just a small
part of your application code base you
can obviously spend time with all the
other partners world but probably this
is where you should start from let me go
over a quick review of what we presented
today and the main benefits we started
with Courtland and we described a few
new compiler optimizations that we added
that focus on coding performance we
describe briefly how we approach costing
optimizations
and that we first tried to seek
improvement in the cotton compiler we
moved to memory and storage
optimizations and my colleague mattress
introduced you to the concept of compact
X this is a new text format available
just own device and we will talk which
focuses on the memory savings and
finally I presented you the idea of
cloud profiles and we talked about how
we can bootstrap the profile guided
optimizations using a small percentage
of alpha beta channel users in order to
lead important performance improvement
right after install time for the
majority of the production users with
this I'd like to thank you for your
attention and for your presence and I
want to invite you all to Android
runtime office hours tomorrow where we
can answer any questions that you would
have about this presentation or about
the runtime in general we're gonna be at
half past five in Section a thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]